good morning Hank it's Tuesday
aggressively unscripted video incoming
so I am in Los Angeles for reasons that
will become clear shortly and I'm
thinking right now about storytelling so
I have often said over the years that I
believe books belong to their readers
like I don't think it matters whether an
author intended a symbolic resonance in
their story as long as it's there
because we're not reading the author
we're reading the book also I don't
think we should privilege the author's
voice when it comes to matters outside
the text like for instance what happens
to characters after the story ends
because I don't think that's up to the
author I think that's up to us as
readers my books belong to me while I'm
working on them and then when I am
finished they don't except there are a
couple problems with this worldview one
it's a little bit disingenuous to
pretend that the author isn't present in
the book at all especially in our
personality driven culture and
especially if the author has chosen to
have a public life by for instance
participating in an eleven year long
video blog conversation and then
secondly there's the problem that while
the book belongs to the reader the
author has to make a lot of decisions on
behalf of the book and that's true even
after the book is published which brings
us to Los Angeles so I almost didn't
sell the movie rights to my book The
Fault in Our Stars partly because I'd
had some bad experiences in Hollywood
but partly because that book was really
close to me a big part about what I
enjoy about writing made-up stories is
that they're kind of coded autobiography
in which only I have the complete key to
the code and TVO's contain not only
parts of me that lots of people knew
about like my friendship with Esther
Earl but also parts of certain traumatic
experiences I'd never told anyone about
I mean obviously it was exciting to
imagine a movie of my book but it was
also scary to imagine some of that coded
stuff being on a big screen for lots of
people to watch also so much can go
wrong I mean they could have changed the
whole plot they could have made hazel an
84 year old survivor of the Titanic it's
actually a pretty good idea for a movie
of the story of the Titanic but it's
around this frame of like an 84 year old
lady who this is not an original idea
anyway in the end I sold the movie
rights and I got so lucky I had no way
of knowing that Elizabeth and Aaron at
Fox 2000 would be the perfect stewards
for that movie or that we would get
amazing producers or the best possible
screenwriters or an amazing cast and end
up with a movie I really loved and then
we got to do it again with Paper Towns
and then I thought well that
was a good run because Paper Towns
didn't make as much money and also
because I decided to write this
extremely quiet novel that takes place
almost entirely inside of one person's
head which isn't the sort of thing that
usually lends itself to film the big
challenge for me and Turtles all the way
down was whether I could use language to
find some sort of direct form or
expression for obsessive thoughts rather
than only relying on metaphor I wanted
to try to give readers not only a sense
of what OCD is like but maybe at least a
glimpse into what it is which is like a
profoundly non visual thing but as Isaac
who produced The Fault in Our Stars and
Paper Towns pointed out to me obsessive
thoughts are also a non linguistic
experience and that didn't stop me from
writing the book so for the last two
months we've been talking about it is
there a way to tell this story visually
without relying on the old tropes that
are usually associated with portrayals
of OCD and today I get to announce that
working with the same studio and
production company that made the Fault
in Our Stars in Paper Towns we're gonna
give it a try that doesn't mean there
will definitely be a movie but it means
that there might be one so now's the
time to begin inundating me with casting
suggestions because no one ever reads my
Twitter bio I'm really excited for the
opportunity and also the challenge of
the turtles all the way down movie and I
hope you're excited too
the book does belong to you but I had to
make this decision on behalf of it I
really trust the people who are working
on this thanks to everyone who's made
the book of number one New York Times
bestseller for now 7 weeks straight and
if you care about the book please know
that I will try to listen to you
throughout this process hank dftba i
will see you on Friday